[Music]
billy eilish goes blonde
this is what i want you know in my
wildest dreams the 19 year old bad guy
singer ditched her signature
neon green and black hairstyle that
she's rocked for a few years now
and debuted a blonde new do billy took
to her instagram stories to tease her
7.7 million fans on instagram
that she changed things up asking can
you guess what color
before revealing her bright blonde look
writing by green it's beautiful in true
billy form she poked fun at the fact
that her sans green
do debut came on st patrick's day
and captioned the photo pinch me duh
the pick billy shared to her ig page not
only shows off her color swap
but her new chop too which features
shaggy
textured layers and bangs really really
cool the singer's new hair
is not what has fans shook to the core
[Music]
hold up has her neon hair been a wig all
along
stop what the hell are you talking about
exactly what we were thinking the singer
shared a clip to her tick tock account
lifting a neon green and black weave
off of her scalp
no word yet on whether the look billy's
been rocking for the past few years has
always been a wig
but fans and fellow musicians are loving
her blonde
do and were quick to freak out over the
major change
singer ash tweeted i'm going to have a
hard time focusing on
anything but billy's new hair today
while paramore's haley williams
reposted the photo on her instagram
story gushing over the new
lil punk rock blondie bill the hairstyle
is a
major switch up for the singer and comes
just
days after she won record of the year
for her hit
song everything i wanted at the 63rd
annual
grammy awards which she accepted with
her former green roots
i'm like through the roof bro i'm just
i'm just happy about it
billy has expressed herself through her
hair for years now
and has donned many styles both short
and long and several different colors
icy platinum blonde purple dude
what like i don't even know gray
turquoise
blue i want to see people go like that
you know what i'm saying
black and of course neon green
which she held on to since 2019. i got
to give it to him
so now the question is do blondes have
more fun